parle
pas fa on un un peu on est un petit peu
en
deuil il est 11h ce matin dans la cour
de l'école Velpo les élèves se recueill
une manière pour eux de rendre hommage
aux enfants de leur âge qui ont perdu la
vie hier à
Toulouse tous ensemble pour lutter
contre cette barbarie pour dire qu'on ne
l'accepte
pas dans ce cours qui laisse place aux
nombreuses questions de cette classe de
CM2 des remarques qui surprennent par
leur recul et leur
maturité en plus parce que pour les
parents après ça ça reste marqué dans
toute leur vie les enfants ont leurs
mots ils ont leur langage faire discuter
les enfants de faire émerger les
questions et à partir de là on essaie de
de faire un jeu de questions réponse
dans la classe pour pouvoir un peu
évacuer un peu ce moment difficile il
sont content d'en discuter ils sont
contents de poser des questions de
s'écouter si c'était quelqu'un qui avait
90 ans qui mourrait c'est c'est même un
juste pour lui quoi la plus grande des
difficultés que l'on a quand on répond à
ces questions c'est de faire très
attention à aux réponses et ça c'est le
travail des enseignants ils sont
toujours en train de se poser la
question mais quand je réponds telle
chose est-ce que je veux pas choquer un
enfant c'est ce que Jul F disait ne
faites pas ce que un enfant ce qu'un
honnêomme pourrait vous reprocher il y a
des mots que je ne voulais pas qu'on
utilise avec les enfants exemple mot
méchant parce que bah des fois il est
utilisé par les parents d'élèves et je
vais pas que l'enfant puisse penser que
méchant égal criminel voilà le dialogue
avec les enfants une corde sensible à
l'Arque des professeurs mais ce matin
dans leurs yeux on pouvait lire leur
apaisement